raven is super explosive in the movement
department yeah but obviously sergey is
just as explosive too we've seen his
back dash into electric right so he's
got those two and honestly in this
matchup right like sir you knowing
sergey he's going for those you know 14
13 frame electrics right as punishes
master raven's not the cleanest
character in in terms of that either
right she has a lot of minus 14s and
this is you
you know minus 3 13 her lows can get
launched in this matchup too so she's
gonna be a little
a little patient here yeah
this is gonna be very good for uh ravens
down back four and down four
saving the wall for the healthy still
gonna have to screw as well
don't want to work out if that combo had
hit i would have been i know
i feel like it was styling
that was 100 on purpose at this point
he's looking at this man he's managed to
use every neutral punch or neutral kick
in every combo so far wow
okay he got the side switch but that's
high wall and the ravens
you know when you find yourself in back
turn for no reason sometimes like that's
the true test of a raven player right to
get yourself out of there safely it's
the surfing combo
my man just showed us the new combo
every single launch
no rerun no rerun episodes around here
dude every episode is brand new
even the filler episodes are new
damn sergey
technician right now oh my god
crew there's the chance
yeah this is big too he carried to the
wall get a ton of damage going to get
the ball yeah
oh no we could attack that yeah they
don't if they don't opt to try to
re-wall splat
and that's what we were talking about
all of raven's lows like that other than
like down three down four and down back
four are gonna get twin pissed and
launched
yeah it's definitely something you gotta
be worried worried about there if your
crew
and sergey right now he's down threes oh
he went for the launch yeah he did
so you know obviously just playing so
comfortable right now feels like oh
he feels like he's in his element
he even tried to get max damage on that
wall combo yeah that would have been
sick i was liking the combo choice there
oh
okay saving himself a factor with the
background jack nice to go forward four
big opportunity not gonna be able to
reach the wall just fight
both for the wall carry though like it
both players just out of range
wow that was beautiful yeah one of one
of the nice things about masturbating
her wood punished game is pretty pretty
strong she has a lot of far reaching
moves but damn
yeah great though you got to be worried
at that got the wall too
and the extra damage what's the okay
here hell sweep up
another hell sleep here could be bad
news i know
oh god that's why they're both kind of
threatened
relentless with the lows he did triple
low at the end he's just like just die
die
see that's
that's sergey and that's a kazuya player
right because he went he he recognized
he needed the low the the lowest to win
but he didn't go for like down back four
down back three he didn't go for
like
real kazooie was he went for generic
down down fours because those moves are
almost like
a key to mashima play right generic down
four is such a pivotal kazuya or mishima
move and so he utilized it perfectly he
knew that i didn't i don't need to throw
these power hits i just need to get
these quick low pokes in to get the win
and man it just felt like ah there's so
many opportunities for crew to even like
get some combos in right he had a lot of
counter hits but just the the mid-range
game he just kept getting getting beat
to the punch
a lot of unfortunate stuff that happened
for crew too he got a lot of
opportunities but the side walls kept
messing it up or the wall came into a
weird spot you know that's like the hard
part about raven right just figuring out
the right formula to get them to the
wall just right just right so you can
set up that wall combo
yeah and even if you do sometimes this
just feels like uh maybe i shouldn't go
for it you know i might i might drop it
here you know that's the reason why we
saw he did get to the wall combo right
crew did but he didn't opt to go for the
back turn re-wall splat right he just
said i'm gonna just finish the wall
combo i know i can get max damage here
or good damage here right so you opted
to go for that still got the kill but
one of those things when it's like yeah
did drop some com some a little bit of
damage there but it's not enough for me
to be like that cost you the game it was
just enough for me to be like oh that's
kind of worrisome just because you know
when you're master raven you want to get
those max damage combos and it's so
scary for him to try to close off the
the rounds with raven with a low right
because there's so many like just
eliminating down four and down bad four
by blocking and launching with kazuya
it's terrifying right and then if you
try to oh wait maybe let me try to use a
safer low with down three or something
but then that doesn't hi crush and then
you get popped in the mouth with the
keep out electric or something you know
so
oh scary choices here scary choices
see how
the crew uh
adapts here
[Music]
oh my god steering edge at the wall wave
electric for the carry look at the stop
wow
oh my goodness bro
hey
hey this guy is not a this guy shouldn't
be allowed to be so cool with kazuya all
right
dude sergey just looking like a beast
right now man
oh man sergey is looking so comfortable
right now and this is the same position
we saw on that evil right coming out of
losers bracket but
dude
you give this guy more games to play
with and he just gets faster look how
fast he's moving now who finds the 34.
big launch
nice and gonna get this oh just goes for
the back one oh okay get the counter
doesn't screw no
i don't know what that jab was i didn't
know what that jab was might have been a
different input something else maybe
wow two hits already
bunch of power is coming out
oh my god the wave of electrics are so
cool guys
this is what crew needs right he needs
to take advantage of these times or so
he's kind of feeling himself by kind of
being a little bit too too aggressive in
that mid range he's got to find the
whiff when dishes but
oh boy
oh god a little greedy for the slide
it might be pink
and the wall kill top 10
oh
no he just turned her into a fireball
dude just smacked her into the walls
oh my god
nice big launch here big opportunity
crew just short of the wall yeah just
got there too but wasn't going to be
able to get too many hits after that got
the get him kicked over
hit the wall yes sir unfortunate recruit
oh you are not
unnecessary he trying to power his way
out traded though no doubt before and
the backswing is good crew's still alive
he's fighting for his life out here
yes sir he's definitely trying to trying
to style on them a little bit can't be a
little risky to go for those back turn
setups too especially against master
raven who does have a back turn stance
out of some counters and things like
that out of that too oh
big counter big counter combos man
these people are making me mad cause i
keep thinking they're all drops right i
heard the gasp in your voice where you
held your brother's like
did he drop it yeah then i saw the rest
of it like that's not a drop-off oh oh
those are so cool
too strong man i love the i love the
wall carries that he does where he just
needs one more hit yeah
the wall and he does like electric
standing one yeah while standing one or
the back three like we just saw there i
really love those and gets the grounded
it down for one after sergey
still in it man still living on the
loser's side over crew